ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello, and
welcome to Google Developers
Live.
My names is Arun
Nagarajan, and I'm
with the Google Apps
developer relations team.
We have a special GDL today.
We have Letter Feed, who is a
great partner of ours, that's
joined in here in the studio.
And they're talk about
the great Google Docs
add-on that they've built.
And we'll actually take
a look at the add-on
itself, but more
importantly have
a good conversation
about how they built it,
and some of the challenges
and opportunities
that they have faced.
So before we dive
into all the details,
let's actually let them
introduce themselves.
CHRIS HAN: Yeah, I'm Chris.
I'm Chris Han, and I'm
the co-founder and CEO
of Letter Feed.
KARTIK AYYAR: Hi, I'm Kartik.
I'm the co-founder and
CTO of Letter Feed.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And for the folks
that are not familiar,
what does Letter Feed do?
What's the product about?
What are you doing?
What are you building?
CHRIS HAN: Sure.
Letter Feed makes
collaboration tools for work.
And we're really
excited to talk today
about Letter Feet Sidebar,
which is a Google add-on.
And it's a single place for
you to see, and discuss changes
to your document.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And who is a typical
user of Letter Feed?
CHRIS HAN: Our typical
users are people
who really depend on Google
Apps to run their business.
They're really heavy users
of Google Docs and Sheets.
And they use it in a
very collaborative way.
So it's oftentimes a lot of
people editing, and viewing,
and just making changes to
these Google Docs and Sheets.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So actually, why don't we take
a look at the add-on itself?
I think that'll set
the stage really
well for some of the
other conversations.
CHRIS HAN: Sure.
Sounds great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's
take a look at it
here in the computer.
CHRIS HAN: Great, so we
can switch to the demo.
So Letter Feed, again,
is a single place for you
to see and discuss
changes to your documents.
And so it lives right
alongside your document.
So that in a single glance,
you can quickly see and see
what people have been changing
and editing, including
who's been changing
them, and when.
So additions are shown in green,
and deletions are shown in red.
And it's also a great
place just to have
any sort of document-related
conversation.
So if I'm making a few
edits here, I can say, hey,
does this look OK?
So you'll be able to quickly
see and discuss any changes.
And any message
that you send will
appear right alongside the
sidebar for all document
editors to be able to see.
Of course, not everyone is
editing at the exact same time,
so we actually will send out
email if they're offline.
So it will actually detect
presence, and send an email
if it's applicable.
So in this case, we're
going to switch over
to our other user
here, who got an email.
And he's able to actually reply.
And say, hey, I'll check it
out in a sec, and hit Send.
And this message will actually
get posted back to the sidebar.
We wanted to make the email
experience really great
because editing in
a team is almost
always an asynchronous
experience.
So we're going to actually
go into the document now.
It's Kartik.
And you can see that
his message is actually
posted on the left-hand side.
KARTIK AYYAR: And an
update also happened.
CHRIS HAN: Yeah, and the
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So
now you're showing
the add-on for two
different users
simultaneously on
the same screen?
CHRIS HAN: Yep.
So on the left, is Chris.
On the right is Kartik.
And so Kartik is able to see
that his message has already
been seen.
So we actually show you
anytime someone has actually
read your message
or your change.
So you'll never have to
wonder if someone's actually
read your document.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
CHRIS HAN: And Kartik
is going to post
a message, which
includes a link.
And any link is
highlighted and actually
intelligently
previewed, whether it's
an article, a link to
a Google Drive file,
or in this case, a photo
of some really cute cats.
And so we wanted to provide
a really rich experience,
so you'd have those
discussions you
need to put together
your document.
So we've also enabled the
ability to just copy and paste,
by dragging and dropping
content from the sidebar.
So any text or photos
that you're discussing
can automatically be
added immediately.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Yeah, and I've been myself,
using it a little bit
here and there.
And I've kind of enjoyed
the constant history
that it tracks, and the
nice way that it provides
the summary of the changes,
not just the snapshots.
Right?
So I think that's
a really cool thing
that you guys are offering.
So tell me a little bit about
some of the technical details
behind the add-on, what
some of the selling
points of integration
were, and if you
can give some
background on that.
KARTIK AYYAR: Sure, sure.
So I think fundamentally
Letter Feed
is like a multi-client service.
Right?
We started off as a
standalone website.
And since then, we of course,
introduced the sidebar.
And so as a result of building
this multi-client service,
we really tried our
best to seamlessly blend
the best of having Apps
Script, plus having
our own service that is
really doing the lifts.
As a result, we are using both
Apps Script APIs, as well as
the [INAUDIBLE] APIs seamlessly.
And to the user, it's
completely transparent.
I think the biggest
thing to keep
in mind is that when you're
trying to actually build
an add-on, test early and
test often with any libraries
that you want to use in
the [INAUDIBLE] sandbox.
And so that way you
can like pretty early
on figure out what is
going to work for you.
Right?
And that will also make
your software development
a lot more predictable.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
What are some of the
interesting metrics
that you'll be tracking
once this launches?
CHRIS HAN: We're going
to be looking really
closely at retention
and engagement.
So on the retention
side, we're going
to be looking at day-one
retention for new users,
to make sure they stick
around, and weekly return
rates for current users.
On the engagement side,
we'll be looking a lot
at frequency of use per day.
Are they getting a lot of use
on it on multiple documents?
And also send side metrics.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's
take a quick look
at the multi-client design
that you talked about.
That's on the computer here,
and of course, you kind of
talked to some of the key
things you've done here.
KARTIK AYYAR: Sure.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: With that,
I mean this is great.
I really enjoyed
using the add-on.
I urge you all to go try it on.
It'll be on the
add-ons marketplace.
And good luck with
the launch, and thank
you very much for being
here the studio with us,
introducing the add-on.
CHRIS HAN: Thanks for have us.
KARTIK AYYAR: Thanks.